joining me now is simon fraser who's a
former head of the foreign office
good morning simon um good morning
you're a seasoned diplomat you've seen a
lot of this um are we really facing the
biggest land war in europe as described
by the prime minister
well of course it's always difficult
disentangle the disinformation from the
from the facts but it does seem that
actually contrary to what a lot of the
experts have been predicting over recent
weeks
we may well be moving in that direction
and we do have to take very seriously
the warnings that are being issued by uh
president biden and the prime minister
and others now i think so the situation
does look pretty alarming at the moment
the um the conference is still going on
but the russians aren't there um
can there be a diplomatic solution if
they just aren't even turning up
well uh it's true that they're not there
and i think that what that tells us is
that uh president putin is not at the
moment really interested in negotiation
and a negotiated solution uh he's made
demands which he knew nato and the
americans could not accept he's kept the
door open a bit through the discussions
of the activity of his foreign minister
lavrov but it doesn't seem to me at the
moment that there is a very active
disposition to negotiate on the russian
side and i mean there are ways in which
negotiations could be taken forward uh
if both sides wanted to do it but one
thing's really important to say we can't
negotiate with russia if russia has
broken international law has infringed
the sovereignty of ukraine and has
invaded so the window for diplomacy at
the moment the current window for
diplomacy does look as if it may be
closing
taking all of that together do you agree
with the europe minister james cleverley
when he says as he did earlier in this
program
that uh an invasion is more likely today
than not likely
i just don't know the answer to that i
mean if you
you know if you look at this rationally
from our perspective you would say that
the risks for putin of doing that are
immense
and he's going to incur huge economic
political
military and human cost uh if he does
that
but what we have to be always aware of
is that other people don't always see
the world through the same perspective
as us and we have to understand the
different motivators that are driving uh
president putin to this action uh even
if we don't agree with them we have to
try and understand them i can't tell you
exactly what's going on in his head and
what he's going to do i think we do have
to take the risk seriously
well what's going on his head as you say
uh is a bit of a a mystery but um the
foreign secretary this morning appears
to
have
better intelligence she says that putin
won't stop at ukraine and that he has
designed on the baltics and elsewhere
um
if she's right that means that this
crisis
has to escalate and at some point there
is going to be
actual conflict
yes i think what he's trying to do is a
number of things he's trying to do he's
basically trying to rewrite
the sort of european security structures
that we've had since the cold war which
he believes have been shameful for
russia a reverse for russia he's trying
to reintegrate ukraine into russia
because that he believes is something he
believed he wrote a long essay on that
recently and it's something he believes
in
he's trying to weaken america and divide
the west and he's trying of course to
bolster
russian uh control through force in the
near abroad all those are recognized
objectives of russian policy and what
he's trying to do actually is exploit a
moment of what he sees to be weakness in
the west and distraction in the west in
america and in europe to achieve those
goals so there is a risk that he will
act in ukraine and of course we must be
aware that he may have broader uh
objectives that's why deterring him from
this action would have been uh ideal and
if we can't deter him we are going to
need a very strong united powerful and
effective response to try and limit any
further action
um
if you were in the foreign office now
how important would you regard what k
bailey hutchinson has just been saying
about the need to reduce european
dependence on russian energy supplies
what she seem to be saying is that the
americans ought to be
ramping up their provision of energy to
europe and building facilities so that
you europe can be if you like um uh
stronger uh in facing down putin
well i mean there's a whole series of
lessons that we need to draw uh one is
of course about europe's uh dependence
for its security on the united states
that's a long running discussion another
is this very important issue about
energy dependency and of course we
should be seeking to address that but
let's not fool ourselves it's not
something that could be solved overnight
there is a whole sort of infrastructure
of energy supply to
europe from uh russia
and from the east which you can't just
switch off
easily because you can't necessarily
replace those resources easily there is
of course a lot going on now at looking
at alternative supplies of liquid gas
for example but you have to have the
infrastructure to be able to do that so
yes definitely we should look at it but
it's a serious challenge
simon fraser thank you so much for your
time this morning
thank you